und jetzt mit heinz wolf und marietta
slomka abend bei politik gehe es darum
das zu machen was möglich ist sagte
angela merkel gestern bei der
vorstellung des klimaschutzpakets der
bundesregierung
vize-kanzler scholz verwies darauf dass
menschen mit kleinem einkommen nicht
überfordert werden dürfen
da sind natürlich auch spd wähler im
blick auf solche die vom strukturwandel
im bergbau oder automobilindustrie
betroffen sind beide ahnten wohl schon
dass sie für ihr maßnahmenpaket von
klimaschützern keinen beifall bekommen
würden
auch wissenschaftler zerpflücken das
paket ein forscher fast auf twitter die
kritik in einem wort zusammen pillepalle
christian von rechenberg berichtet wenn
eine politikerin sagt politik ist das
was möglich ist dann meint sie
wir haben das notwendige nicht erreicht
gestern sagte die kanzlerin diesen satz
gestern präsentierte ihr kabinett das
klimapaket das eigentlich eine klare
vorgabe hatte
[Musik]
hört auf die wissenschaft auch das sagte
die kanzlerin gestern das sagt die
jugend jeden freitag hat das kabinett an
so richtig zugehört das kieler kabinett
hat in gewisser weise die wissenschaft
komplett ignoriert das kann man nicht
als klimapaket bezeichnen noch nicht mal
als päckchen das ist in gewisser weise
sterbehilfe für das weltklima weil etwa
der einstiegspreis von zehn euro für die
tonne co2 für die tonne sein
im gegensatz zum zaghaften klima paket
fordert die wissenschaft anfangs den
fünffachen preis sonst könnte man es
auch bleiben lassen
generell reagieren die menschen wenig
auf steigende spritpreise und steigen
wir energiepreise vor allem bände liter
brennstoff nur ein paar müde cent mehr
kostet politik der kleinen schritte
aus angst der wähler mache ihnen sonst
die hölle heiß wir dürfen nicht zögern
wir dürfen vor allem nicht das signal
geben mehr klimaschutz passiert dann
irgendwann mal sondern wir müssen jedem
einen anreiz geben und jeden das signal
geben möglichst früh in moderne technik
zu investieren damit zu warten wäre
fatal denn deutschland ist verpflichtet
ab 2022 jedes jahr eine fixe menge
kohlendioxid zu sparen
ansonsten muss es sich
verschmutzungsrechte kaufen
das könnte für den finanzminister im
betrag von 3 bis 6 milliarden sein
wir haben ja noch mehr beschlossen
verteidigt sich das kabinett höhere
pendlerpauschale etwa teure flugtickets
förderung sauberer energie allein diese
maßnahmen passen nicht zusammen wir sind
unkoordiniert sie neutralisieren sich
teilweise gegenseitig und gehen auch in
die falsche richtung und am ende des
tages werden sie eher zu mehr emissionen
führen als zu weniger emissionen weil
etwa all die menschen die teuren
flugtickets ausweichen wollen kaum
alternativen vorfinden
weil die höhere pendlerpauschale mehr
koste als der co2 preis einbrächte
kann man alles nach steuern konnte das
kabinett jedes ressort werde ab jetzt ja
streng kontrolliert das nach steuern
über solche hier in keiner weise denn es
ist letzten endes so dass wenn
ministerien ihre ziele nicht einhalten
dass man dann zwar neue pläne vorlegen
muss aber es hatte auch keine
konsequenzen das heißt also insofern
wird wahrscheinlich alles so weitergehen
wie bisher
erreichen was eben irgendwie möglich ist
klima retten und die konjunktur
kritik daran so absehbar wie deutlich
und aus sicht der wissenschaft wohl
notwendig derweil gab es heute bei den
vereinten nationen den ersten jugend
klimagipfel an dem natürlich auch greta
tonwerk teilnahmen aber nicht nur sie
zeigte das ist in dieser generation eine
ganze menge junger menschen gibt die
sehr politisch sind sehr ernsthaft und
rhetorisch sehr versiert und das muss
man ja auch erst mal hinkriegen sich
quasi vor die ganze welt öffentlichkeit
zu stellen und so eindringliche reden zu
halten
johannes hano bei new york dabei mit
einer indianischen segnung zeremonie
wurde der gipfel heute morgen in new
york eröffnet eine prophezeiung der
xerox häuptlings crazy horse habe sich
erfüllt
harte zeiten stünden der menschheit wie
vor nur gemeinsam könne man die großen
probleme lösen
dieser zeitpunkt sei jetzt gekommen
unter großem beifall wurde greta tun weg
die ikone der neuen umweltbewegung
begrüßt gestern hatte sie vor 250.000
menschen gesprochen heute geht sie sich
zurück ich möchte nicht so viel zeit in
anspruch nehmen ich soll schon am montag
auf dem weltklimagipfel sprechen
ich möchte den anderen hier mehr zeit
geben zu sprechen
600 jugendliche aus der ganzen welt
nehmen an dem gipfel teil 100 von ihnen
hatte die uno eine co2 neutrale anreise
finanziert und die delegierten machten
gleich zu beginn klar worum es geht
ich komme von den pazifischen inseln
eine der regionen die am wenigsten zur
klima krise beigetragen haben die aber
am meisten unter ihr leiden unsere
häuser versinken unsere gemeinden lösen
sich auf für viele hier geht es um 36
oder 70 gigatonnen co2 im jahr
aber da wo ich herkomme geht es um unser
dasein es geht darum was lebt und was
stirbt klar unmissverständlich und
konkret dann die forderungen auch an die
staats- und regierungschefs die in den
nächsten tagen hier in new york über die
maßnahmen zum schutz des klimas
verhandelt wir fordern dass sich die 100
firmen die für 71 prozent des weltweiten
treibhausgasausstoßes verantwortlich
sind auf einen weg zu mehr
nachhaltigkeit gegeben
wir können das schaffen wenn wir
zusammenhalten und sagen
genug ist genug wir wollen keine
fossilen brennstoffe mehr jugend
klimagipfel ins leben gerufen hatte
stießen die delegierten auf offene ohren
subventionen auf fossile brennstoffe
sind unsinn besteuert co2 emissionen und
senkt dafür die steuern auf arbeit um
die menschen zu entlasten und antonio
guterres fordert die jugendlichen auf
weiterzumachen nicht nachzulassen
meine generation hat eine große
verantwortung aber es ist eure
generation die uns in die verantwortung
nehmen muss damit wir die zukunft der
menschheit nicht verraten
der erste jugend klimagipfel für die
jugend delegierten ein erfolg das war
sehr anregend und wir hoffen dass unsere
punkte jetzt in die
un-generalversammlung einfließt
es sind hier so viele leute da die dinge
verändern und das gibt hoffnung dass wir
eine nachhaltige welt schaffen können am
montag auf dem klimagipfel der staats
und regierungschefs wird sich dann
zeigen welches gebe ich die stimme der
jugend denn wirklich hat mehr infos und
hintergründe zum jugend klimagipfel und
zum klimaschutz paket der
bundesregierung finden sie bei uns
natürlich auch online auf heute.de
wenn am montag die katholischen
deutschen bischöfe zu ihrer
herbstvollversammlung in fulda zusammen
kommen wird es auch um den sogenannten
synodalen weg gehen
hinter diesem etwas sperrigen begriff
steht eine gemeinsame debatte mit den
katholischen laien über alle themen die
spitze der missbrauchsskandal das
eheverbot für priester die
machtstrukturen innerhalb der kirche
sexualmoral und die rolle der frau nicht
jedem deutschen bischof gefällt das und
auch nicht jedem im vatikan von dort gab
es schon kritik
doch die mehrheit der deutschen bischöfe
glaubt inzwischen dass es besser ist
offen zu diskutieren als debatten zu
unterdrücken
zumal beim missbrauchsthema das ja noch
lange nicht aufgearbeitet ist
viele täter wurden bis heute nicht zur
verantwortung gezogen
die menschen die unter ihnen litten
warten weiter auf gerechtigkeit
susanna santina mit einem beispiel aus
dem bistum limburg den sexuellen
missbrauch an kein moritz hatte der
priester fritz p schon in einem brief
von 1997 zugegeben indirekt als er
schrieb ich weiß ich bin schuld und
schäme mich so vor allem hoffe ich dass
es für kai noch nicht zu spät ist kein
moritz war damals anfang 20 und hatte
sich im vertrauen an eine enge freundin
seiner verstorbenen mutter gewandt ihr
erzählt dass fritz behn schwer sexuell
missbraucht hatte sieben jahre lang es
begann als er zehn war und nach dem tod
der mutter pflegesohn des priesters
geworden war
am anfang als ich bewusst dass
aufgearbeitet habe ich ganz oft duschen
müssen er weiß nicht einfach
was körperlich eklig war das ist so eine
kategorie
das ist schwierig weil das feld nur auf
mich selber zurück
ich will mich davon nichts zu fressen
lassen
dazu gehört auch dass kein moritz
gerechtigkeit erfahren möchte dass der
mann der ihm so viel leid zugefügt hat
bestraft wird fritz p der heute anfang
70 ist wurde zwar vom priester dienst
suspendiert ist dabei als fahrer erst
2011 offiziell aus gesundheitlichen
gründen in ruhestand gegangen bei der
verabschiedung mit dabei der frühere
personalchef des bistums limburg dem
sich kein moritz viele jahre früher mit
anfang zwanzig anvertraut hatte
befremdlich sei das gespräch gewesen
weil es ein absoluter mangel an empathie
ist der da zu tage getreten ist als es
ging von anfang an darum was alles nicht
geht was unter der decke zu halten ist
also so stichwort dieses gespräch hat
nie stattgefunden oder ok wollen sind
therapie ich besorgt ihn ein ja und das
ist ebenso es tötet nicht aus der ist
von anfang an nicht aus der
opferperspektive gedacht worden
und fraglich ist auch warum dieses
gespräch in dem der personalchef des
bistums limburg von dem sexuellen
missbrauch durch den priester fritz b
erfuhr nicht dokumentiert wurde
nein es gibt nichts es gibt keine
hinweise auf das gespräch und es gibt
keine hinweise auf missbrauch in der
personalakte ist es üblich dass man wenn
man so ein gespräch führt wo es um
sexuellen missbrauch geht das sagt
nichts dokumentiert wird nein das ist
eigentlich nicht üblich und mit blick
auf die leitlinien die es seit 2011 gibt
ja wäre das auch ein ding der
unmöglichkeit
und hätte man das gespräch mit keinem
moritz damals dokumentiert und wäre
anzeige erstattet worden wäre der fall
nach weltlichem recht nicht verjährt der
bischof von limburg glaubt kein moritz
das hatte georg bätzing bei einer
pressekonferenz im april gesagt und eine
kirchenrechtliche untersuchung in
auftrag gegeben die jetzt zur
entscheidung beim vatikan liegt kein
moritz beklagt dass der täter bis heute
kaum konsequenzen spüren was wirklich
nach außen hin auch
die gemeindemitglieder oder auch kirchen
volk oder auch eine breite
öffentlichkeit erfährt das hat dieser
mensch gemacht es hat viele therapien
gebraucht kein moritz glaubt dass er den
jahrelangen sexuellen missbrauch
einigermaßen verarbeitet hat auf
gerechtigkeit warte er bis heute und
jetzt die nachrichten
nach den angriffen auf saudi arabische
ölanlagen verstärken die usa ihre
truppen in der golfregion
das hat das verteidigungsministerium
angekündigt generalstabschef dann fort
sprach von einer moderaten verstärkung
in folge des angriffs vor einer woche
war die öl produktion eingebrochen und
der ölpreis kurzzeitig gestiegen
die usa machen iran für die attacke
verantwortlich
iran bestreitet das in brandenburg haben
knapp drei wochen nach der landtagswahl
die grünen den weg für ein dreierbündnis
mit spd und cdu frei gemacht auf einem
landesparteitag stimmten die delegierten
überraschend deutlich für die aufnahme
von koalitionsverhandlungen
zuvor hatten sich bereits die
landesspitze von spd und cdu dafür
ausgesprochen die wirtschaftsleistung in
den ostdeutschen bundesländern ist in
den letzten jahren deutlich gestiegen
das melden verschiedene medien und
berufen sich auf den jahresbericht
deutsche einheit der bundesregierung im
vergleich zum westen lag die
wirtschaftskraft im osten im vergangenen
jahr bei 75 prozent
1990 waren es über 43% löhne gehälter
und private einkommen erreichen
inzwischen etwa 85 prozent des
westdeutschen niveaus in münchen hat am
mittag das 186
oktoberfest begonnen um 12 uhr zapfte
der oberbürgermeister das erste fass
bier an
und updates die wiesn gilt als das
größte volksfest der welt sie dauert in
diesem jahr bis zum 6 oktober und es
werden wieder rund sechs millionen
besucher erwartet
die lottozahlen dieses samstags sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
12 14 16 23 37 47 superzahl 6 und
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotter punkt zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 56 und noch die wetteraussichten
morgen ziehen im südwesten wolken auf
sie bringen am späten nachmittag
einzelne schauer sonst scheint bis zum
abend die sonne
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 19
und 27 grad
die kommende woche beginnt mit 14 bis 22
grad deutlich kühler und unbeständig am
montag regnet es in bayern anhaltend
haben dienstag gibt es ganz im westen
schauer am mittwoch über all das was man
uns und jetzt geht es mit dem aktuellen
sportstudio weiter
danach so 0 25 gibt es die nächste heute
express bis morgen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]